today we're speaking with one of the
most popular streamers in the world
amaranth even though you might know her
from her hot tub streams or a vice
documentary where she shares her one and
a half million dollar monthly income
behind the scenes she's a business
Savant who owns multiple gas stations
Texas real estate and one day has a
dream of opening up an animal sanctuary
I was running a character company for
children's birthday parties did you own
the company yeah that you did wow I
didn't expect to learn so much about
marketing and business from this but I
did and you will too although before we
go into that Jack I have to say you've
been wearing that shirt non-stop every
single time I've seen you recently and
we're in that exact same shirt I can
wear it like five to six times maybe
tens of times and it doesn't stink so
that's a huge Plus for me you know it's
funny I was wearing the exact same shirt
for like days in a row until Macy made
me take it off and put it in the wash
she made you take it off yeah she's just
been wearing it too often Unbound Merino
is sponsoring this video that's the
clothing we've been wearing right now
not even exaggerating I have been
wearing that exact shirt non-stop I love
it Unbound Merino is a clothing brand
that uses the ultimate travel fabric
Merino wool which is perfectly optimized
for packing comfort and maximizing your
travel experience the Merino wool is
incredibly light moisture wicking and
odor resistant and my favorite part from
all of this is that it almost feels like
you're not wearing anything because of
how soft it is seriously guys I wish you
could just reach through your phone
screen right now and grab this shirt
because I have never had a shirt that
felt like this ever before and trust me
it's insane unlike all the other
performance clothing brands I've seen
Unbound Merino offers exceptional
quality and style I'm about Marino could
help you pack less and embrace the
freedom of a minimalistic lifestyle so
check out unboundmerino.com and don't
forget to use code iced coffee at
checkout for 10 off on top of getting a
really really nice shirt you're also
supporting this podcast it would mean a
ton thank you so much Unbound Mourinho
and back to the podcast thank you for
having us over you have a beautiful
house thank you you gave us these
chalices yeah these are actually the
prop maker from Game of Thrones these
are the Queen's goblets from King's
Landing beautiful where do you get these
Etsy really yeah they're on Etsy even
this is like so fancy I saw these for
sale at Fred Siegel and they're like 200
each that was Amazon uh a pack of eight
for sixty dollars there we go yeah no
way better very fancy well thank you so
much for having us we've had an amazing
day so far we went to a ranch we saw
horses that was the first time I've ever
pet a horse I think congratulations so
yeah it's really nice you live streamed
which is crazy yeah that was scary that
was horrifying grandma and I were so
nervous about that yeah if you get
killed by the horse it's live that's
true that's true yeah you had a really
nice uh chat though on the stream yeah
they're pretty friendly yeah I wasn't I
wasn't expecting that I was expecting a
whole bunch of just like just angry
comments and like mean remarks but like
I went on there everyone was super nice
and then Alex goes on and I'm reading
the comments everyone was like W Alex go
Alex hi Alex it was really friendly I
wasn't expecting that yeah yeah yeah no
but I had the animal streams that's when
the wholesome people come out really the
degenerates don't care about those
streets they'll come trash talk my game
player okay my bikini or something but
when it comes to animals everyone one's
pretty nice is there like a time of day
thing where in the afternoon like you
get more of like the friendly people
whereas at night you get like the d-gens
morning is way more friendly okay
because Europeans they they're they're a
nicer culture yeah they're a finer breed
of chat do you know yeah so tell us a
bit of your background how did you get
started doing all this well I started in
2016. I started doing twitch back then
um because at the time it was already
cosplaying a lot I had like a little bit
of an Instagram following a little bit
of like Facebook deviantART used to be a
like art photography platform I don't
know if you remember that I do back in
the day now no one cares about it but I
had a tiny following there but back then
it wasn't really saturated like it is
now so a small following was still like
whoa you have a thousand followers wow
right now it is though too many people
so twitch was trying to expand their
creative program uh now you might people
watching this now be like wait that was
a thing exactly they stopped hearing
about it pretty fast but they invited
cosplayers to it and they wanted us to
make costumes on live stream in their
creative category and the incentive was
that if you come on and you create
costumes we will lower the amount
required to hit partnership a few counts
because it used to be 500 viewers
concurrent gaming to get partner okay
but with creative it was only 100
concurrent viewers so what's a
partnership do it gives you sub benefits
you get like more of the revenue split
you get emotes and stuff um so basically
you can monetize your Channel at that
point but until then could you could you
monetize it all or it just wasn't as
good only donations got it okay so you
didn't get any sub money no it's not for
a partner yeah really wouldn't that
unincentivize people from like subbing
though well they couldn't subscribe
unless you're oh you couldn't subscribe
right oh wow and now they have an
affiliate program but before there was
no affiliate it was just
partnership or bust basically
interesting yeah okay so that got you
onto twitch yeah and then after they
stopped doing the creative program push
um IRL category started surging up so I
kind of just like switched into that
with my uh partnership already that I
had gotten kind of like on easy street
or whatever because I kind of got in
there before most people could and so
that kind of propelled me forward and
then IRL was just going off which is in
real life people who don't know twitch
and that was when you started having
people doing non-game play activities
like going out kind of like live
vlogging yeah at conventions or
traveling or just talking to people too
to the chat without playing a game was
considered IRL yeah was that common
Before ice Poseidon because he was the
one that kind of introduced me to that
whole like IRL streaming him and was it
Andy Milonakis yeah I think yeah a lot
yeah and we would see him because I used
to work in Sunset Boulevard and I would
see him with the self Museum yeah yeah
because he was walking on Sunset Plaza
and he had this selfie stick with like
like three cameras and like lights
shining on them and he was always like
walking up and down the street and then
you go to like a restaurant and just sit
there and place it down on the table and
it was usually like just him and he'd be
talking to it while ordering Foods wild
yeah but I was but I was always too
afraid to go up and say hi Oh yeah yeah
but you knew who he was I knew yeah oh
yeah he's hard to not recognize right
because people are just like who is this
12 year old out here yeah who was this
40 year old lady yeah I remembered it
from MTV yeah yeah the MTV show so what
were you doing at the time to sustain
yourself or was twitch enough well white
roof for twitch I was running a
character company for children's
birthday parties so like it would be
Disney without saying Disney right the
copyright free terms for Cinderella like
Snow White
um
else and Anna like frozen you know so
you would dress up like I would dress up
and then I had girls too who would work
for me and that we would all go to
parties and do events and we would Make
A Wish Foundation stuff we would do like
festivals around Houston
um I got to be on like a TLC show The
Little Couple they had a birthday party
and they hired me to be there as the
Snow Queen Elsa
um it was really cool because I got to
throw the first pitch in the Astros game
as Elsa because they had like a mommy
and me day sure so it was really cool
opportunities like that and did that
make good money it was pretty good money
for like a non-social media now we all
of our expectations of what's good money
is completely skewed but back then it
was like 200 for an hour are you sure
that's fantastic
even with social media money I mean
that's still decent right but only on
weekends right but still but like an
actual like you do that like two hours
like 400 a weekend is fantastic yeah it
was crazy good margins too because then
you would get the costume and you could
wear that for like a year two years yeah
right so it was actually incredibly
profitable for the time but the
unfortunate thing is well fortunate for
me not fortunate people who stayed in
the industry things like covid are a big
killer of that industry because then
people just stop having parties for a
year two years three years so that
really sucked but fortunately I made the
switch before covet hits yeah yeah but
it was super fun because I would get to
go to these extravagant parties it would
be like big homes like this sometimes
like in nice neighborhoods and they
would have a carriage waiting for
Cinderella to come in so it's like you
got to be worshiped and get paid
basically what were the kids like when
they hired this out like most of the
kids were nice like respectful oh yeah
most of the kids would listen to you
more than they listen to their parents
they respected the royalty I believe it
wow so how much would the parents spend
on one of those parties like I'd imagine
this is like a 3 000 kids birthday party
oh probably more than that when you get
into like the like the River Oaks
neighborhoods like the really nice
neighborhoods for Houston area like
Jesus this house is alone are probably
like five to ten million dollar range
you can imagine is how much they throw
to kid party I think some of them
honestly cost at least ten thousand
dollars for like a four-year-old's
birthday party that's correct I don't
even remember being four yeah because
they would have multiple princesses they
would have the horse-drawn carriage they
would have a face painter they would
have the bouncy houses they would have
the catering the decorations sometimes
they would bring in a petting zoo oh
it's just like a birthday party a
standard birthday party for the rich
person yes the rich people houses yeah
okay so you were doing that work and
then you switched over to twitch when
did you make that switch what was like
the twitch income versus that income
that you can justify going all in on
Twitch well I was doing both for a bit
um and then I guess I was doing twitch
for about six months so uh beginning of
2017 is when I kind of decided that I'm
going to switch from going to the
parties myself to doing the streaming
thing and I'll just send my girls out
so I was still managing it but
um I was training full-time instead did
you own the company yeah that you did
yeah wow yeah and so what would you pay
the other princesses like they would
just pay you a package deal and you'd
pay the people underneath you less yeah
like starting out was like probably 60
an hour and then I'm still pretty good
if you're just like dressing up and then
it would go up to like 75 or 80 an hour
too if that has been with me for
business yeah how did people find you
did you market like that's the thing I
got into it via Facebook advertising a
little bit of Google advertising too
that's actually how I got the idea to
just go full time into social media
because I was already using the skills
of social media marketing with my
business and I was thinking like this is
the future is everything's gonna be
online moving that way if I have this
skill I should just go into social media
full time go straight to the source
rather than just using it to Market a
limited business that can't really grow
Beyond Houston without a bunch of Hassle
and headache thinking about licensing
and where do you get that mindset though
because not everyone thinks like that
like where did that start you have
parents that thought that way it's like
something you saw someone else do that
and you're like that's a good idea I
think I saw it mostly because um I would
be in a lot of these cosplay groups and
a lot of the cosplayers were doing this
kind of thing too but in other states
like California and it would be really
popular
um California was a big one I think
Florida was a big one where the parks
are right but so they would know they
would be able to go to the park frequent
enough to know what the characters look
like know how to model the costumes know
how to act and everything but then be
able to bring that into like a party
atmosphere and it was a very hot Market
because it's so much cheaper for some
parents to hire the princess for 200 an
hour than it is to take their whole
family to Disney for the day you know
and yeah for all their friends but like
the business aspect of it like where do
you get that from
I think were you like that growing up as
a kid no no no no no I I was not at all
I think it was just from watching
observing like seeing how they were
expanding their businesses and like how
they were advertising so I would get
their Facebook advertisements like
suggested I would be like in their
groups actually have groups for it so I
was just watching and observing the
different princess company groups and
seeing how they were advertising and
stuff and then I I tried it myself and I
found it very effective I don't think
it's nearly as effective now Facebook
advertising because they've raised
prices a lot but before I could put like
10 to 50 dollars into a Facebook
advertisement and make like a thousand
dollars in party bookings although
before we go into that guys sorry for
the interruption I do have to say that
lately I've been taking my health a lot
more seriously I've been going to the
gym and getting a good night's sleep and
I've been eating a lot healthier with
their sponsor factor I recently went on
vacation with Jack actually and I came
back and I was like seven pounds heavier
and it was from not going to the gym
eating lots and I just became kind of
lazy so when I got back been getting
really into Fitness in fact there's
something thing I've really really
really enjoyed this sense is a whole
bunch of their meals and I have to say
I'm obsessed with them factors meals are
also ready in just two minutes so all
you have to do take one of these out
from the refrigerator put it in the
microwave two minutes later it's ready
to eat and it tastes really good you
have to try it to truly appreciate it
but it is really really really good they
make meeting your nutrition goals easier
than ever by delivering fresh never
Frozen dietitian approved meals right to
your doorstep their team of gourmet
chefs create each meal using only
ingredients with Integrity to help you
feel your best all day long when I'm
trying to decide what I want to eat I
take into account three things how
affordable it is how quickly I can get
it and also how nutritious it is and
Factor actually checks all three of
those boxes when usually I only need a
check too you could even choose for more
than 34 Chef prepared dietitian approved
weekly options featuring premium
ingredients such as broccolini leeks
truffle butter and asparagus or you
could also try the beverage options with
smoothies shakes and juices Factor saves
me a ton of time and a ton of money I
would highly recommend it if you're
curious what it tastes like we have a
link Down Below in the description or
you could go to factor75.com and use the
code ich 50 for 50 off your first order
enjoy and now that it's said let's get
back to the podcast have you always been
interested in business
not really no I think it just happened
when I was like going to school for
costuming was looking for money on the
side because eventually my my dream was
to do like Hollywood like costumes you
know for Marvel or for like Lord of the
Rings type stuff so I was kind of just
trying to figure out how do I take my
costuming skills right now and start
making money because I'm not at that
stage in my life and it kind of just
rabbit holed me down into like the
business side of costumes like with
princess stuff and cosplay and then that
led to social media so kind of just all
like piled together unintentionally for
me and I was just watching and observing
and then trying it I was like oh but it
seems to have a normal job
um the most normal was working at the
Opera in ballet making costumes I guess
and then I worked for some other
companies before doing my own princess
company like I was I was just like a
contractor not really an employee but I
would be the performer without owning
the business or owning the costumes and
then I was just like I could run this
this I can make better costumes than
these and they just kind of did it were
you a good student like throughout
middle school high school yeah pretty
good student I would say
um yeah I think High School I was like
all in all the AP classes and then
um for a while I was number one in my
class and then I and then I got lazy and
I dropped a number 20 when I graduated
but it was there was eight there was
like eight to nine hundred kids in the
class so I guess it's still pretty good
why do you get lazy it's very good yeah
yeah what happened there why did you get
lazy a senior yeah really yeah I got
tired of that yeah but there's
operations in high school were to become
a costume maker yeah so it was like this
I realized like none of this matters
yeah
just like in One Direction you're like
heading true north and you're like okay
just stop here stop here stop here but
for the most part you kind of like just
like slowly progressed yeah because I
got involved in theater in high school
because first I was like do I want to be
an actress and I was like maybe but I
kind of like the aspect of dressing up
and like the creation behind it so then
I was kind of leaning more towards into
a costume inside of theater did your
parents have any expectations of you of
like you know we want you to be a doctor
or a lawyer or like anything like or
were they like very free that you could
pursue what you felt was best they're
pretty free they just wanted me to
figure it out so at some point I could
stop living under their roof okay they
were not really picky though what I did
um and I think that's
standard for parents who also were not
like particularly High achieving so know
if your parent was like a lawyer or a
doctor had a very successful business
they like have expectations for you but
for my parents my mom was a preschool
teacher for like her whole career and my
father
worked with computers in I.T but not
like coding or anything crazy like that
just like software testing so it wasn't
like either them were super
entrepreneurial or like super um I guess
educated on like an advanced level with
like doctorates and things like that so
did they ever teach you about money no
not really how did you learn about money
I had to have like a good education even
going through and running your own
business yeah a lot of it was um I had
an uncle who was actually running his
own small businesses not like anything
super big scale but that's kind of how I
got started like learning about the
business side and social media marketing
because he had to do it he was actually
a dog walker but it's like how do you
let people know about that you have to
start it with social media so I would
like listen to him talk about money and
stuff and then I would kind of like do
when I started doing my own business
with the princess stuff I'd have to look
around like on Google and like figure
out things like how to do taxes and
things like that so just like I learned
as I went I didn't have like a formal
education if I just need if I needed to
figure something out I would just Google
it we always uh self-reliant when it
came to that sort of stuff yeah it was
pretty self-reliant I guess because you
know none of my family is particularly
successful yeah so I don't have anyone
to turn to I was just like well let me
just go to Google and YouTube and things
like that and just try to have things
explain to me because for me it's like I
went to school for costume design which
is not also not particularly a good
Avenue for learning anything with
Finance or business related at all so
what do they teach you in costume design
just like what materials to use I feel
like that
maybe this is insensitive maybe I don't
know how much here we go Jack I feel
like look I take one semester right what
materials for what colors for what like
volume like how voluminous you want
something to be that's kind of like
right it wasn't that basic it was more
like it's actually really interesting
because it went through fashion history
so you learn different periods of like
historical fashion like Georgian you
learn like like the Regency period of
Victorian age it's like super
interesting to see how the the fashion
tastes evolved and then it went from
like being very basic like togas and
stuff like with Greece and then it
evolved into let's put a bunch of layers
on and cinch it all up and then it got
very relaxed again in like the 1900s
where do you think we're headed towards
I think honestly I think I think we're
gonna get in like it's not gonna be
wetsuit material like neoprene but I
think it's gonna be like a one suit you
just step in and then you're inside it's
like a it's like a morph morph suit or
whatever I'm like more comfortable like
Nanobots you know where it conforms yeah
and whatever you want it to look like
exactly Perfect Fit yeah and then you
can like yeah it's like super aerated
and breathable and stuff like that yes
yeah I think we're going towards that
honestly I think we're going straight
utility and then people are gonna think
it's cool I was about to say I think
we're going back to the 90s fashion
that's what I was about to say what does
that look like
yeah like in the media future yeah it's
so weird like The Tick Tock kids they
all look like my 90s it's like big wash
jeans yeah the tie dye and like yeah
yeah
yeah yeah you know one day we're gonna
go back to the Ed Hardy days where it's
like the shirt designs you know that's
gonna come back
yeah the you know Jewels it's gonna come
back okay
I had the shirts the t-shirts that had
like the design prints on the one side
looking back it's awful yeah what was I
thinking with the baggy jeans yeah
that's a great look man so so let's talk
about the twitch success was your was
your growth linear was it exponential
what methods did you use to grow on
Twitch because I heard we've had a
couple twitch people in here right I
think one of them said like what you
have to do is just stream for as long as
possible because like then people they
like open up the stream and then they
leave or they walk to the you know the
nearby McDonald's or something but their
stream is running like on the computer
what strategies did you use to grow on
Twitch it's a bit complicated because
while that in theory is the best way if
you already have a following
um that was what the algorithm will
reward is you stream you stream you
stream you stream and that will
recommend you to more and more people
because it's you're watched your
accumulating watch time even if you're
not the most watched out of say like two
people together uh so you both stream
five hours just because somebody watches
that person more and the five hours does
not mean they'll get recommended more
because what happens they log off if you
keep going you'll eventually surpass
them so even if you're not as popular
you know with like view count or things
like that as long as you accumulate that
those minutes of watch time it'll build
up in the algorithm will recommend you
more at least that's how it's been
working when I was like really popping
off this year I've been kind of sporadic
I've been moving and boxing and all
these things
um but it's tough because there's no
really discovery on Twitch other than
the recommendation section or like if
you're on a category page people don't
tend to scroll down the category it's
like the top 10 what they can see within
the browser window without scrolling
that's what they pick on because people
are lazy so you actually have to grow on
other platforms more where there is
discoverability like Tick Tock is a
great way now like Twitter Instagram
that's how I agree with Twitter
Instagram and then a little bit of
YouTube but YouTube doesn't isn't like
as easy for me because it's always
changing the algorithm and it'll stop
recommending if you're like too sexy so
so what would you do would you just post
like cosplay stuff stuff and and then
people just found you organically
through those platforms then routed you
towards the the twitch yeah and also my
Facebook cosplay page but eventually I
stopped doing cosplay as much because it
just wasn't as profitable it's actually
it was actually really sad but that's
just the way humans are you would make
this amazing armor piece super accurate
you address about this character and
you'd get maybe like 5 000 likes and
then you dress up in a misty cosplay
which is a tank top and booty shorts
from Walmart that took you five minutes
to put on and it's like 30 000 likes
is most of the appreciation of
cosplaying is that like coming from a
male audience or is it a female audience
is it like the intricacy of the costume
itself or is it just the way it looks
like what is the appeal because I've
personally never been super interested
in cosplaying but I'm trying to
understand like what why people like it
well I think the people that appreciate
the art the most are probably women more
than men because that seems to be like
the type of people who go into it
because it's like wow I'm making this
thing it's so cool it's so crafty look
haha it's so fun but they tend to do it
more because they can monetize it
whereas it's harder for guys to monetize
cosplay so you end up getting just a
bunch of women who are into it mostly
and then
um the audience though who looks at
Women's pictures and likes them and
engages with them typically are men and
the men are going to respond more to the
the sexy character than they are like
the armored up authentic looking World
of Warcraft build right right it just is
you know that is the nature of
sexuality you know so it's tough for
sure have you noticed that
um costumes for Halloween if you look at
Women's costumes it's like sexy uh
nonsense
and then you look at Men's costumes
banana you know what I mean
yeah yeah funny or scary do you think
that that's kind of
going down the wrong direction because
cosplay is more than about just being
sexy right yeah I think the crafting
part of Cosplay definitely is more about
being making it for the art of it like
if you compete you do like competitions
at conventions it's definitely for the
art of it or if a if you can monetize
like if a gaming company hires you to to
cosplay a new character and like promo
at ad events or on social media then you
can kind of get paid for the art of it
but for the most part you know the best
monetization is always just going to be
the sexy route and so people would start
doing this thing like bikini versions of
characters like they'll just like make
it more sexy character yeah
to me it's like I think I approach it
from a very logical standpoint if your
goal is viewership how do you gain the
most viewership if that's the way to do
it that's the way to do it right it's
like I just look at what works you have
to look at your motives right are you
trying to make the most amount of money
that you can while you're young and then
do whatever you want to enjoy or are you
trying to share your love of the art and
that's all you care about is sharing
that love and finding people who also
resonate if you have other things going
on in your life you don't need it for
money whatever yeah or if you want to
just go the the harder route and
monetize the actual character part
because people will do that they'll just
have a different type of patreon or
whatever or Etsy if they do commissions
themselves or if they do tutorials for
making stuff like it can't be done it's
just typically not as much money as
quickly yeah yeah so it's very it's
perfectly reasonable like to if they
want to do it they can make a lot of
money doing it compared to like a nine
to five yeah but we're not talking about
like Millions a month only fans low
profit margins low times spent like just
like super profitable in that direction
so it just depends what you want yeah so
how long did you think it took for you
to make like six figures like a
six-figure salary on a monthly basis on
Twitch was it like six months a year oh
on Twitch it's harder because on Twitch
it didn't really start getting that to
the six figure mark from twitch alone
until hot to meta that was I think 20 20
one I believe yeah and that kind of
exploded so I think after I crossed like
6 000 concurrent viewers or whatever at
the time is when you started getting
into the six figures six thousand
concurrent viewers yeah that's a lot
yeah and I was only hitting the six
figures
um monetarily too because I was
streaming for so long so what was your
schedule like like when did you begin to
realize that like streaming more is
better I started realizing that around I
guess late 2017 2018 because I I've been
streaming like really long since then
because when I first started streaming I
was doing maybe three to five hours at a
time just trying it out playing some
games cosplaying making costumes and
then I Rose it to like eight hours ten
hours 12 hours sometimes I would do like
14 18 hours sometimes I would be on even
longer if I did a sleep stream things
like that could you explain a sleep
stream where you literally sleep on
stream so you're streaming you keep the
camera on while you're sleeping but
it's like a virtual Slumber was it we
should sleep stream tonight I would be
down to sleep stream tonight um we don't
have an audience to stream to yeah we
just post on Instagrams like hey check
out our songs no I want the donations
like I want that we'll stream on YouTube
well they can we just do it on Twitch
I don't want one dude just one dude just
watching us the whole night yeah waiting
for Alex to like hold on to his side
with the same viewer so what's the okay
what's the appeal of sleep streams like
why do people tune into that
um different models because for guys
they typically get more money doing it
because their chat's trying to mess with
them and so their chat will be like
playing react content like they'll be
doing Media Share to try to wake the guy
up or just make each other laugh but
girls chats environments aren't quite as
like haha bumping elbows buddy buddy
they're more like
I don't know what the word is uh sexual
I guess so they'll be like like what if
she starts taking over top right now I
forget she's streaming oh my God if she
forgets she's yeah she could forget
she's like but people are commenting
this yeah stuff like that or like what I
would do to her right now like while
she's sleeping some people are really
creepy and others are like why are you
guys watching this y'all are weird
they're like criticizing each other for
watching it while they're watching it
it's kind of funny so do you get a good
night of sleep when you're sleep
streaming because I feel like I could
just not sleep I do I have this
incredible talent to fall asleep
anywhere regardless of how much light
how much noise how whatever's happening
so I I can get a pretty good night's
sleep I actually used to get more sleep
doing that than why because I would have
chat hit sub goals to let me sleep
longer to justify not being productive
for those hours okay so I would get like
19 hours of sleep and how much would you
make in a sleep stream I don't know it's
hard to quantify that because I never
broke a down like that because it'd just
be one continuous like 24 hour 48 if you
were to just guess I would say probably
uh if you count just on Twitch
probably
I don't know like a couple thousand
dollars but if you count like the
conversions potentially to only fans
yeah while I'm sleeping because they're
clicking on links and whatever
um then maybe like
ten to fifteen thousand that's wild yeah
so why not just do that every night I
would see like 10 grand a night and say
I may as well do this now like I'm not
gonna do it forever but like hey every
single night the scheduling gets
complicated and then also um because I
have photo shoots and stuff I have to do
like the next morning sometimes or if
I'll have sponsorship but couldn't you
just end it when you wake up like wake
up be like all right stream thanks so
much I'm up now
see ya there's an angle potentially
maybe that's a good idea but maybe maybe
I just switched to I only stream my
sleeping and then I enjoy rest of my day
yeah working while you're sleeping has
there been a time though where you've
woken up and forgot that you were
streaming or does that not happen no
it's never happened okay so far
um I don't do it as much I don't know I
feel like if you do it too much it would
become no longer novelty okay but maybe
what I would should do instead is I
should just invite girls over for
sleepovers and we only stream us doing
like getting ready for bed activities
sleepover stuff and then we stop
streaming we wake up then you can call
it sleeping with whoever in the title
yeah genius that's genius
I think if you were to stream yourself
sleeping that's a untapped opportunity
that I think so many people could get on
because you're not doing anything anyway
so you may as well be working while you
sleep I think that's the most useful
myself
over and over sleep stream only like you
started an hour before bed and then you
end it like you know 30 minutes after
you wake up
who's gonna tune into that after like
four times okay so Ram has this idea in
his in his brain he's always been this
way where he's just like do more post
more content it's about the the work and
the volume it works because it's like
it's a treat right it's once in a while
people right like I think that there's
when the doors open you walk through the
door
that's what I think
but you can leave the door open right
now
what could work to change it up while
we're sleeping different girls coming
over we're sleeping maybe a higher
people to come in and do random stuff
you know the night yeah so people don't
know yeah like if you get like up to x
amount and donate donations or whatever
like something happens or whatever yeah
like the top donations like a mariachi
band comes through the door yeah yeah
but you have to but you have to have
them on standby I mean that's something
yeah but you're making that kind of car
you're making it
don't think that like people would watch
her every single night if she's just
doing that yeah do you agree yeah I do
okay all right
I think
all right okay if it was with other
people maybe what other kind of like
variety streams would you do
um
because you you jumped on the the what
was it the hot tub yeah did you come up
with that
no I already been doing like pool
streams but
um one of the girls decided to do like
inflatable hot tub and they were doing
it outside and I then the thing I did
pioneer was moving it inside where you
can control the lighting control the
Wi-Fi control everything you don't have
to can like move ring lights outside and
just like just put it in my room look at
the hot stuff on the ground and then
that's what everybody started copying
that because it is just so much easier
you don't depend on the weather your
ring light's already right there you're
right next to your setup the Wi-Fi is
better how long could you be in the
jacuzzi for
how would you not turn into a prune uh I
would you would I just didn't care was
it painful at all like you because I
would get out like Graham would be
completely devastated I'm just saying
when you're in water for that long your
hands and feet shrivel up to a point
where it's like it could be painful
okay what temperature was the water
was it like a 95. I would start at like
104 when she heated up all the way yeah
then throughout the day it would if okay
you don't want to have it on because
it's really noisy yeah it's like like
the whole time so I would turn it off
when I start the stream and then
throughout the day it would get down to
like 70 degrees oh wow eventually yeah
how much did your numbers go up when you
started doing that I went from like
maybe like anywhere from like four to
five thousand viewers concurrently
before the hot tub to then uh at one
point it was hitting like 20 22k yeah
yes wow yeah it was pretty crazy and so
but how do you one-up that because is
there that pressure where it's like
you're doing that well and you're like
what's next how could I like keep on
this this same path yeah well at the
time the drama aspect was kind of doing
the job for us we didn't really have to
innovate much because people were acting
like it was such a controversial topic
like hot tubs while in the same category
as me that looks so bad to sponsors but
they were like really angry about it
um and so that drama of trying to get
the hot tubs banned people complaining
about it so much online kind of kept the
interest alive for the hot tip sector
because they get viewers coming in be
like what is this thing they're doing
what is this stuff then they would like
just start arguing in the chat whether
the hot tub should even be allowed on
Twitch or not
um and then when they finally when
twitch decided to make the hot tip
category and shove us all in there is
when people really stop doing it because
the discovery went down and
unfortunately yeah what was the reason
for the hot tub in the first place I
think it's just a way to kind of subtly
convert people to your only fans I did
not find out about you through the hot
tub drama that was going on how off I
found out about you was this um this
bath water thing oh yeah now when did
this come into play uh because that like
made headlines I was like oh this
person's selling bath water when did
this come into play in terms of like was
it uh when you first started twitch was
it in the middle of it and also did you
actually
that you make sales yeah I made a lot of
sales um that actually was more recent
compared to the rest of my career I
think that was last year maybe like
early 2022
or maybe maybe late 21 somewhere like
that it was kind of Blends in for me but
um there was a woman who was doing
fart jar cells
um and she is it Belle that was that was
original bath water one okay but there
was a woman doing fart jar sales at the
time
and she was supposedly making a pretty
good amount of money like like on a
couple hundred thousand dollars from it
but then she stopped one day and she
claimed that her diet to make her
make so many fart jars hospitalized her
I think she actually got covered and
changed the reason why she was in the
hospital personally but then she decided
to switch to nft fart jars which were
not as successful and I don't know how
that would work anyways
um and so I kind of took over the vacant
spot available for fart jar selling I
was like well no with her out of the
market your competition the demand is
incredibly High
and um I I joined that and then I was
like well I'm at it since I have all
these jars and I sit in a hot tub I
might as well sell my hot tub water
all right
first of all
how's the audio sound is she close
enough I was gonna ask her if she could
just come in a little closer oh
sorry
about that nice catch see if I did that
Graham would be he'd be like sure how
could you how could you just it slipped
like this and then I went to save it and
I over corrected sorry about that
it'll make for a great clip
what do you think about the ethics of
porn is it ethical is it unethical
because when we shot with Brett Cooper
she was sharing her opinion on why porn
is unethical oh what were her thoughts
on that she thought basically it kind of
like promoted the objectification of
women and that it's not good for the
young male mind to see women especially
like on your phone you know the high
availability of porn just like on your
mobile ease of it exactly wherever you
want to watch it you can watch it and I
think that she thinks it's also like
corrupting a family unit because like
then guys can just like instead of
finding a girlfriend or feeling an urge
to find a romantic partner
um just going on their phone and getting
that instant gratification and moving in
the next day yeah I don't know it's
decide though where though where it's
actually
better for guys to be able to have that
kind of sexual release because then if
say they're really bad at socializing
and they're not quite all there they get
that frustration those urges out in
private instead of bothering women in
real life and potentially doing
something crazy because they're so
frustrated you know
um so I don't know I can see both sides
I guess as far as the ethics of it I
don't think it's unethical if both
people are consenting and they're happy
about like what they're putting out
there and the amount of money they're
getting paid or whoever's involved it
had to be two people to be an orgy I
don't know or solo whatever
um I think nowadays it's actually even
more ethical because instead of these
big companies making porn and
controlling like the financial aspects
of it people getting ripped off who are
at the performers now they can just make
their only fans and set their own prices
to whatever they're happy with and do
whatever they want on their own terms so
I think it's actually getting more
ethical
as like it's the sexy platforms where
the individual is able to monetize by
themselves keep coming up so you argue
that it could be a benefit for people
watching porn specifically dudes because
then maybe it like kind of it's that
sexual release rather than right
releasing it at a time where it'd be
highly inappropriate yeah maybe they do
have a date planned but they they do
their beforehand so then when they go at
the date they're not just thinking about
how to get in your pants only right
maybe that's like that release is done
and they can actually focus on the
interaction if they do want a genuine
connection rather than just being you
know horn dogs the whole time because
they're so frustrated I don't know I
feel like it can only be beneficial
because if it was if porn didn't exist
they would find something to fap to
still I'd feel like the answer is not to
remove faffable content I'm sure even
back in the caveman days it's like
scriptures on the cave and like they
found like a rock caveman erotica with
like stick figures on a wall of like
doggy style
Commerce just with sex in general
because yeah it's been around yeah no
definitely I feel like it's actually
um the creation of porn and allowing
people to just make it freely like only
fans and stuff has actually reducing the
need for people to feel like they have
to be prostitutes to give money because
instead of actually having sex with
people on the street now they can just
upload a video and make money you know I
think just everything in moderation yeah
everything as long as it's not getting
in the way of your job right but that's
also up to them the individual's
discretion right right so like to
determine when it's an issue versus just
self-control self-control
me too just like let people do what they
want in their place also who can see how
like porn could actually keep a
relationship together because say like
the couple's very busy or they just the
magic of like the intimacy is gone but
they still get along as a couple instead
of him leaving to go find a mistress
maybe he just faps to porn and then they
say together hmm so I don't know I see
both sides I don't see it doesn't have
to be homeworking I feel like people who
are going to be home Wreckers are
probably going to be cheaters or
whatever regardless whether if there's
porn out there or not so yeah I tend to
agree with that I don't think that would
be the sole reason yeah unless of course
you just get carried away with it right
with anything yeah
interesting yeah people who are going to
be addicted to something could be like
any addicted to drugs or gambling or
whatever it is okay this might be an
uncomfortable question but like I said
you're welcome to not answer it if you
want to okay yeah I just figured they
were kind of an intriguing question to
ask let's say you have a daughter would
you be comfortable with your daughter
doing the same thing that you do for an
occupation oh I would definitely be
comfortable with that you'd be totally
fine yeah I would be totally fine with
that because she's she's able to do it
from the comfort of her own home she's
not having to go out and put herself in
like weird situations to try to make
money because it's like sometimes you
know in like the the business World
we've seen women who feel like pressure
to sleep with the boss or whatever to
climb their way up socially it's like
with online stuff she can make however
much money she wants doing whatever she
wants because there's lots of people who
make their money and they don't even
have to like go all the way maybe they
just post sexy pictures you know just
whatever she's comfortable with you know
in the comfort of her own home with
whoever is consenting and she gets to
decide that I think that's awesome it
gives her the power to do it anywhere
she wants without having to feel like
she's a slave to the nine to five grind
that you know the rest of society often
gets sucked into I think it's cool if
she was down for her to be like okay
I'll just give her some advice on how to
put her identity out there in a way that
doesn't give away like her address and
her full name like give her like a
Internet safety guidance it's like okay
here you go you've had some interesting
run-ins with that because yeah didn't
you have like a fan set a trash can on
fire or something like that it was yeah
to arson
arson incident yeah okay so that's not a
common thing Graham has never
experiencing an arson instant what was
what was that like uh it was very
strange because I heard a loud bang I
was playing video games I think I was
playing Diablo 3 when it came out and I
was in my room but I heard like a Bang
from this like outside somewhere and so
I went to go look I couldn't figure out
what it was as I got closer to the
kitchen like the driveway is I started
to smell burning and I'm like I leave an
oven on to leave the stove on or like is
there a heater that's left on somewhere
like what is happening and I couldn't
figure it out because like nothing was
on nothing was in the Attic didn't smell
like a heater going crazy and then I
looked out my kitchen window said like
the blinds on it I had to pull back the
blinds and my trash can was on fire
and unfortunately it was in the one spot
where I didn't have a camera the one
spot did they know that possibly yeah I
feel like they were probably trying to
find something to do yeah
um because my trash can I wasn't at the
street they had to come up like to the
in the driveway in the bang was because
it exploded against the garage door and
like the metal reverberating no way yeah
and so like I exploded in the trash can
uh I think there was like uh some
alcohol bottles okay so if they drop
like a match in there type of thing or
something okay or like maybe they had
something also like that would burn like
at some if they dropped a bottle in or
something I'm not sure
um because there was already bottles in
there right so like all the things that
could have blown up for like already in
the trash can anyways but yeah that's
what the police suspected because it
happened like in the mid like in the
middle of the night and it wasn't in a
place where it would overheat because it
was covered like under the garage awning
so it wasn't like the sun beating down
okay
so it was very scary though because it
was literally like five inches away from
my Jeep tire and then also two inches
away from grass oh man yeah it was just
like a perfect like meltdown not
touching anything jeez that's freaky and
like the trash can melted to the point
where then it became like a flat piece
of like melted together plastic with all
the contents inside like like on top of
it like a work of like modern art almost
because it was just about this big how
long is it on fire for
uh I think about 30 minutes and was
really unfortunate is that because I get
swatted so much when I called in about
this the police didn't take it seriously
at first this is before I made the safe
word yeah
and so they thought that I was a
prankster on myself whoa yeah that was
an issue so they the the police were
like five minutes away right and it took
them like 20 minutes to come out and put
the fire out yeah did you not want to go
out there with like a hose and just like
spray it down no because I didn't know
if the person did it was still lurking
around sure yeah because it was the
night time it was dark oh wow okay yeah
hmm yeah tricky what are some other
experiences you've had or some like
let's say
unexpected uh let's unexpected things
that would happen that come with like
this level of fame
um I guess more expected but another
thing that I had to deal with is
stalkers showing up at the house
that has been super scary because there
was a I don't know if you read about it
the guy from Estonia
there was a guy from Estonia who I had
convinced himself that he was going to
marry me and he had sold all of his
possessions
back in Estonia even his house even sold
his cat or did something this cat got
rid of it and he brought just like
himself I guess some clothes and
um like a saxophone case because he
played saxophone to America and was just
streaming himself trying to find me
trying to get me to come find him he'd
put where he was in his titles of a
stream and it was like
um like Alec plus Caitlyn forever it was
amaranth forever the title would change
sometimes but like at this Starbucks
waiting for you was he getting viewers
he's got like four or five but that's
enough of viewers to like uh to attract
haters to egamon and try to dox me and
stuff and they did they they gave him my
address because they might you know I've
swatted so it's already doxed and then
he showed up trying to break into my
house essentially like to him I'm sure
he felt like you know he wasn't trying
to cause harm but it's like when
someone's that crazy they can't be
harmful yeah and so he was trying to
like get into the house he would try to
open the doors try to like go around to
the Windows like tap on the Windows
trying to find a way to get in because
he felt like he was there and that I was
gonna be his wife was was he like I mean
obviously he's not mentally right sound
what happened to the guy
I called police on him and they detained
him the first time they took him
somewhere I guess and then they dropped
him off I guess somewhere like away from
my house and he was issued at like a
trespassing
um but like order I don't know what it
is warrant or something like that yeah
and so then he disappeared for like a
year and then he came back same thing
again tried to come to my house and
everything called the police on him and
this time they like they arrested him
actually and they threw him in a jail
cell
so he's still in jail I don't think so
he has been released wouldn't he be like
deported you would think that but
apparently they don't do that unless
it's like a felony and apparently
stalking and trying to break in your
house is not a felony how long can you
get like a travel visa to the United
States I have no idea like there's got
to be a limit where he's got to go back
you would think so I don't know what
that was yeah but it's not the it's not
the responsibility of the local police
to check your Visa status
unless there's something that triggers
it like a like a felony interesting yeah
because that's not their job they don't
have a database of your legal status
here got it when was the last time he
tried like tried to do anything
was that March wait like recent recent I
also have the big guard dog too that
guard dog was scared that was a freaky
he is so attuned to knowing when
something is wrong because the first
time that the guy showed up at my house
that he hadn't even come up to the door
yet he was walking up the driveway
quietly because we saw on those camera
footage after what he was doing and my
dog the second he set foot on the
driveway part when it starts going up
the ramp my dog started freaking out
barking and he couldn't even see him no
window no nothing like just in clothes
in a room he just heard it and knew wow
yeah I would not want to come face to
face with that dog yeah I know that was
horrifying face to face to face that was
horrifying so I see you're gonna be
boxing in August right no July 1st July
is it July 1st I have one month that's
coming up I know so how did so what led
up to that why why say I said boxing
well it was a really cool invite from
the Spanish streamers like actual Spain
and they invited me to participate in
their version of creative Clash kind of
it's called La villada it's the third
time we're doing it third year and the
before like their boxing events you
think career Clash is big no no no it's
not
love a lot it gets like two to three
million concurrent viewers oh just for
the online portion and this year they're
having it at the biggest stadium in
Madrid it's like a brand new football
stadium soccer whatever you're gonna
call it 60 000 seats sold out within an
hour
who else is fighting like how big of a
thing is this
um it's mostly Spanish humor so most
Americans won't really know them isn't
streaming huge in Spain though oh yeah
it's big that's what I thought yeah
Spanish streamers yeah yeah it buys the
one hosting it he's got so many viewers
all the time he's huge he he's Spanish
streamers are so big to where they get
invited to just like cover the the
professional football games
over there like so they go on the field
they interact with the players they get
their own VIP room to stream reacting to
the games business yeah no they're huge
they're like celebrities over there wow
like actual like celebrities like people
think like oh streamer YouTuber
celebrities no no it's not the same
so how much of this for you boxing is
like a business move to get your brand
out there and get your name out there
versus like this is a personal thing
that I want to do to tell me about okay
it's probably about like 40 opportunity
and sixty percent I want to do it
because
the thing that I said yes to was when I
saw that they used the the helmet
because I know that it can still be like
impact concussions but at least less
chance of a broken nose sure so like
faster physically recover time
um and I just think it's such a cool
experience to be like invited by people
from a foreign country and to go to
Europe yeah and I get to experience all
that and I'm the only American invited
so that's cool I felt like it was a huge
honor right so it's like oh okay so
what's it like for you training right
now uh right now I'm training each of my
sessions are two hours and I'm training
like three to four times a week
so it's it's hard to balance it all
because I'm in a mixture of going to the
gym and then my coach coming to my house
yeah are you sparring at all I'm about
to be I'm yeah if we're working on that
this week get as much sparring done as
possible so I'll say I under trained
I should have been doing like five to
six days a week
uh and I was doing one hours but like
five to six and sparring way more I
sparred three times before the fight and
that did not prepare me at all like I
should have like Michael Reeves sparred
like 12 times and Michelle
sparred like 30 times it was like a few
dozen times and she was sparring like
really like good people yeah I'm lucky
though because uh Spain does not have
great boxing coaches or really any
boxing champions so her experience and
her her like available resources are way
less than ours are in America
um so her technique does not look very
good and she's like physically condition
wise I'm like much more athletic so it
looks like I had the advantage right now
luckily who's your opponent meiichi
she's a Spanish dreamer how old is she
same age as me 29. okay we're the same
height same age same weight technically
but very different uh physical condition
sure yeah
so what's a part of your training that
you're doing right now are you doing
like cardio and then the pads it's some
cardio it's mostly technique and pads
and footwork and things like that
um yeah just practicing the technique is
the most important so that way like you
can put more power into each punch and
like work on your stability so you don't
just like tumble over and stuff
yeah for me I think the cardio is the
big one because you get winded so fast
like doing the sparring one minute feels
like 10 minutes yeah no it's crazy it's
like the mental aspect too just really
gets you when you're there it's like
everything you learn kind of goes out
the window yeah it's wild yeah I think a
lot of it's going to come down to just
instinct which is why I'm focusing more
on learning good technique rather than
sparring with bad technique so I'm
hoping like to train muscle memory it'll
just kick in when I'm like on autopilot
you know yeah
so it's tough though to juggle that with
the streaming because as we talked about
the time is worth so much money yeah
because even though like they're they're
they do pay for your trip and stuff they
try to compensate with your time it's
not the same yeah amount of money is how
much my time is actually worth yeah so
it's difficult it seems as though at
least right now you're kind of not
slowing down a bit but like taking it
easier
things like that to people oh it does it
does seem like that because they don't
see how much like I'm doing on the back
end so for me I feel like I don't have
much more free time than I ever did
before because now I'm just doing a
bunch of different stuff yeah so yeah
the boxing takes up so much time
yeah for me it was the time leading up
like an hour leading up to it I couldn't
work because right in my mind I'm
thinking okay I gotta finish up this and
like I can't fully Focus right and then
so that's an hour at you know before and
then an hour after I get back I have to
shower and then it takes me time to like
get back yeah it cuts in even though
training's two hours it cuts into like
four or five hours it's a day oh yeah
it's crazy and then you do that however
many times a week it's like it's
productivity cut in half even though
you're not having more free time yeah
are you nervous going into it not really
nervous I guess more of excited to get
it over with so that I don't feel like I
have to juggle as many things
I get that that's how I felt afterwards
I was so happy that it was over yeah
yeah I was so happy but I thought if I
could do that I could do it anyway yeah
so yeah because originally when I agreed
to it I thought I could be able to
stream all of it but it's it's hard to
be able to stream all of it because you
don't want your opponent to know
everything yes yeah so then you realize
like oh actually I don't want to teach
them how to how to box by watching me
because that's the advantage I have an
American is better coaching you know
what Michelle did and her did he watch
for a boxing video you gotta watch it
watch your boxing videos like watching a
movie so just like yeah just for the
storyline you gotta watch it but she
said she hired a team of people to
full-time watch uh Andrea botez all of
her streams just to see if she revealed
anything about her boxing training so
that they could use that study against
it and she said like months into it she
released one teaser video on her stream
and the other team or Michelle's people
caught that analyzed it and then they
adjusted her training based on that on
like a quick 20 seconds at a month
it was wild so yeah I mean you're right
on in terms of streaming but uh
yeah I can't believe it I saw when
Michael Reeves posted he did like a
quick thing on like Instagram or
something like that and went around and
I showed it to my boxing coach and he
was looking at he's like okay we could
do this I see what he's doing we could
do this and that's why I never posted
anything on myself
yeah it didn't work it didn't work
anyway but
but like I can just show you personally
I would love to yeah my opponent
now while you're pulling that up have
you thought about monetizing your boxing
by like taking like photos and oh that
would be good sets like because I feel
like you know nothing like I'm not
saying anything too explicit but like
you know
you could be doubling up the work you
know
yeah this is an idea I guess for me it's
like I need someone
to help facilitate that and then they
could be making more money at home yeah
oh
um
the wraps yeah with uh she sold out she
sold them out yeah wow and those weren't
even used no it's a good idea okay those
were new and those were brand new ones
they look cool though good job Michelle
I did I thought it was it too niche of a
product but the fact that she sold out
was amazing pretty crazy like how many
people are gonna buy hand wraps for
boxing but people feel inspired because
she also released the the boxing program
so if you sell that with the boxing
program people are going to buy it so
that they can go train you know what you
should buy your boxing program
oh that's not enough ideas my coach is
does not want to release any of his
teachings otherwise he would do it
himself have you changed up your diet
um not really I I've cut down on like
sugary stuff that I can't analyze you
know like if it's like a smoothie or
whatever then I I don't know the
mattress of it but I won't do it but um
for the most part I've already eat
pretty healthy so I'm just like
increasing protein really okay yeah so
that's about normal for me we're trying
to find if anyone clipped any boxing but
most of the clips are just bikini stuff
uh how many people do you have working
with you right now
to handle the whole business oh at the
office like the the one my immediate
assistance there's like
four or five full-time but then like if
you do like the extended Universe of
real work right it's like 17 employees
roughly and what is that what do they do
um they help manage accounts of other
creators they're the only fans like
they'll help send out content and stuff
um make sure it's uploaded get sent to
fans things like that so yeah they help
manage like just other creators
social media or like their paid
platforms fans the only fans
Etc and how do they find creators to
help out
um right now we have like girls who
approach us really for looking for
management but uh we'll also just like
send out messages to people if we if
it's someone like who I'm friendly with
or whatever to ask if they need help
with anything because we'll like offer
like dmca Services too or sometimes
girls will have an issue where for some
reason they've been locked out of their
only fans account like there's like a
ban or something suspended to put on
their account by the algorithm because
it detected something was against TOs
and so we'll help them get back into it
because we know the people add only fans
who can unban them I think those girls
that you reach out to for management a
huge perk would be they could join you
in a sleep Stream So it keeps it back
for you and it's also like you know
mutually beneficial relationship they
get the exposure of being no definitely
it's better for everybody yeah they do
get priorities for like collabs and
things yeah I heard a rumor actually I
don't know if it's so much of a rumor
but that you watch Netflix while you're
Twitch streaming or you watch shows like
you're not fully present while you're
doing it uh I used to do that more
during ASMR not only do as much ASMR
these days but uh yeah that has happened
before yes on my side monitor if I was
feeling too sleepy I'd put on like a
movie or a show and you wouldn't
explicitly tell chat like hey guys I'm
watching like not necessarily sometimes
I would but a lot of times I'm just like
watching it while I'm like doing my
little here's some more stuff how could
you how could you focus on doing two
things at once well if you've done it
ASMR for a long time you realize a lot
of it it doesn't require focusing so
explain what can you do ASMR on one of
these microphones yeah I'd be like
scratching like oh let me turn it up oh
oh I got it I feel like Whispering like
this or like switching the microphone
that is so satisfying honestly was it
really yeah
[Music]
your turn for ASMR I want to see what
you got I don't get it I don't yeah do
it hey guys
make sure to subscribe and hit the like
button
give it a gentle tap
add me on Instagram oh it had me on
Snapchat as well I'm posting Vlogs on
there now so you'll be able to get it
behind the scenes I think
Grandpa smart
and smash the like button
now okay let me give it a shot Alex all
right before you do that I gotta say
yeah hers is way more like
like some I've never listened to ASMR on
headphones it's Game Changer I feel like
you need more seconds in your mouth
Graham I could tell like hers was better
okay Jack go ahead go ahead okay
hey guys check out the iced coffee hour
Club iced coffee hour dot Club if you
guys want some exclusive content because
we got some really exciting stuff going
over there an extra episode every single
month you can only find it there
we can even do ASMR if you guys want to
do there we're pretty flexible
wow dude anyway you like that yeah but
you laughed in the mic in my I'm sorry
ear anyway that was really good
especially though you liked it oh that
was good that was good yeah yeah I feel
like that's the part people like in
asmrs when your mouth starts clicking
you know yeah yeah they love the mouth
clicks yeah I heard a story about you
trying to get a monopoly on like of
content or hot tub live streams because
you had this back and forth with this
other girl and it was competitive back
and forth between you and her then
something happened with pickle Ricks I
mean lots of things have happened with
pickle Ricks yeah something about all of
them I know okay so so what happened
here what was the story so
um the hot tub meta after I brought the
hot tub inside people started doing that
so then I started buying floaties for
the hot tub people started doing that
and I noticed every time I bought a new
floatie suddenly everyone would buy that
floaty uh because it was just like
Amazon Prime or whatever I got a banana
floaty suddenly people would have the
same banana floating and be doing the
same thing I would get like a unicorn or
something they would get the Unicorn I
do the same thing so I was like I want
to get
something funny but I don't want
everyone to just copy right away because
it's not funny very long so I got pickle
Rick and what I did was I saw their only
like 20 available
and left in stock and I bought all of
them because I knew that they'd have to
wait for a while for the vendor to
restock because it was the only pickle
Rick floaty
see that's pretty smart yeah I bought I
bought 20 of them because what were they
like 20 a piece you know what you should
have done is create your own floaty I
thought it was sold them everyone else
who wants to buy them I should have done
that yeah or floaty with your face on
them didn't you have everyone else I
read something about a pool floaty
company or something
uh yeah yeah that was part of the
private Equity they had like oh okay
yeah a deal with them you know yeah I I
should have I guess I was just too busy
like on the grind because of how much my
time was worth I didn't want to put that
much mental energy into it but yeah that
would have been hilarious
um so yeah I bought all the pickle Ricks
and it worked because for like like
three weeks maybe maybe a month no one
else had a pickle rate and then did
people get Pickle Ricks yes no way when
they got restocked they actually bought
them so you did the right thing speaking
like it proved you right yeah to do that
yeah because it'll look like they were
all copying me after it became
established and I'm the one with the
pickle Ricks wow yeah because it all
happened during the same time no one
really knows who started it they just
see a bunch of girls like why is
everyone bananas yeah yeah so what are
you doing today to remain like that
competitive
um today I don't I only have
as much like I don't have like a meta
right now I guess because I've been like
so distracted between moving and boxing
and all these other platforms too now
um yeah right now I guess I'm I'm still
trying to get there I want to become the
party house because I have like this
huge space yeah and you see there's like
contractors here still because they're
still doing some construction but then
after they're done I want to be able to
like host events here and fly everyone
in and do like big slumber parties with
girls wow you know if you're looking for
attendees you know you're looking to
fill some space just hey just go ahead
and let us know
okay whatever
seems like you're kind of trying to
downplay a lot of your accomplishments
up until this moment because like you're
walking us through your story and
there's no chance that you were that
lucky that many times in a row where
like just like the natural flow of I
don't know the current you were in just
kind of took you to success after
success after success
I feel you need it yeah well I think
it's also just hard work too because
it's it's the willingness to be on and
do things people aren't willing to do
because a lot of girls like who use
their body for money you know there's
like a reason they they do that is
because it seems like a shortcut right
and there are a lot of girls who will
spend time doing that but in the
streaming space Also there's not that
many who are like super hard grinding
um and we'll just be on as long as it
takes
to I mean like get that efficiency out
of their works a lot of them still want
to enjoy their time they want to like
travel they want to have free time and
that's nice but I'm like paranoid you
know I don't know how long it'll last
you're very much goal driven towards
having a sanctuary and like building up
enough income yeah it's like I still
want to go and I want to de-stress on
certain mornings but like I don't you
know I'll go to the bar and I'll come
back right and then I'll work it's not
like I'm traveling everywhere so you
think one of the main things that sets
you apart from the competition is the is
the the work ethic yeah no definitely
because it's like you have to be online
in order for the algorithm to go in your
favor because for twitch they they
reward time streamed and nowadays like
you can you can kind of piggyback if you
get like a an org like otk or or someone
or offline TV they kind of like they
feed off of each other because they're
using the same fan group essentially so
that fan group who's like a fan of the
cons and I also go to like every stream
and so your streams don't have to be
long to get viewership or stuff because
you're all just sharing one big audience
essentially but if you're kind of by
your yourself you don't have that like
feedback loop from like this character
Arc of like stories all intermingling
and you kind of just have to grind out
the algorithm hours if you're a solo
person what's your biggest insecurity I
would say maybe
my inherent entertaining level because
by myself it feels like it's hard to
keep up with what currently people find
entertaining because they do find like
drama drama drama entertaining and it's
hard to kind of farm that when you don't
have a Content house or like other
streamers that you're constantly
collabing with to kind of feed that into
so you think that you need to chase the
trends in order to be entertaining you
think that you don't have that innate
just like ability to no I don't think
and it also is harder too for women
because we aren't as seen as like
relatable by the majority of twitch
audience which is male you know people
typically will watch if she's attractive
but they don't really watch because they
feel like that they relate to her per se
that some of the females might but
that's not the majority of twitch
audience still it's still mostly males
so it's kind of hard to feel like you're
entertaining truly because part of it is
like yeah they are there for your
appearance you know that's like the
value that a lot of them found you
through and some will stay for your
personality but there's also some weird
stigma behind like why watching women
still so like she's not gonna any
of you you know people say that in the
chat at each other being like why are
you guys watching just donate And
subscribe she's not gonna you like
as if like that's the only reason why
they would associate with women is to to
be able to them they're still very
much like that that dominating um
societal stigma I guess now what do you
feel like the reason is that they're
there watching for such a long time I
think some have just like from a kind of
uh Community feeling because they talk
each other in chat right and they'll
like support the stream they enjoy the
streamer's personality they just feel
it's kind of like a a virtual hangout
session you know
um it's kind of some it's similar to why
some people support guy streamers but
there's just less who feel like they can
enjoy a female streamer if she's not
them worth that fantasy isn't
there that she might one day maybe
so some are just like very naysayers
when you watch a female she's not gonna
sex you because they don't see females
as like friends or entertainers right
they see females is like an accessory
so what do you think is the biggest
threat to humanity
biggest threat to humanity oh god
um I think ourselves destroying the
planet
not having environmental changes I think
it's not only the environment changing I
think it's just humans like destroying
ourselves either like both the
environment but then also each other I
think we like the social media aspect
encourages drama and conflict and
disagreements and you see people doing
crazier and crazier things AI as well
which is human generation AI is the
least of my concern to be honest I think
it's more of what people choose to do
because you see the news covering only
negative things people are more likely
to to go on crazy violent rampants if
they feel like that's what's getting
that's what we'll get them attention
because it's like the media while making
people aware of it is also kind of
glorifying like shootings and things
like that Stories the names of the the
people that do that which I think is
kind of nice yeah
that's true but I don't know if that
really helps as much if you're already
insane yeah you're just like I want
people to talk about me whether I think
that was actually a really good answer
yeah yeah I agree with that completely
yeah how would you fix the economic
crisis
no but I feel like if you just
eradicated humans like the world would
probably Thrive like environmentally I
would I would actually 100 agree with
you probably yeah yeah I don't want it
to happen right but that I know that it
would be yeah I have to be better for
virtually every other species people are
like oh no the world is dying we should
leave and go to Mars I'm like you know
what we probably should and the world
Wouldn't Die you know yeah it's like
let's go to before it dies maybe the
world will come bounce back there was
like some kind of limitation for a bit
in Beijing you know how the pollution is
really bad there where like I don't
remember a few years ago now maybe
several years ago where they had a
mandate where like the driving was
restricted and within two weeks of
cutting down on the amount of people
driving like the skies cleared up and it
was beautiful and there was no more fog
yeah interesting yeah so I feel like
it's just humans like we're the biggest
threat to ourselves all right also I got
a question because I asked you earlier
if you're a vegetarian you said no but
also you have this like crazy intense
Passage yeah for Animals yeah it's weird
I know why uh why because I'm the exact
same like I love animals I'm the same as
same as grandma you know a little spider
gets inside I'm gonna catch it and you
know release it outside I'm not gonna
kill it squish it or anything like that
very passionate towards animals I love
all kinds of them but I still eat meat
like what's your justification for that
I don't know I don't know if I really
have a justification other than like I'm
a product in my environment and I grew
up eating meat so like I don't know it's
kind of just like I'm used to it now and
and in the back of my mind like it does
bother me but uh currently I guess I'm
just not in a position where it's like
there's enough of a replacement that I'm
like oh like available all the time
where it's like if I'm if I crave
something because I've grown up with a
Janine I don't feel good about it but
it's also like
if I if it's a hopeless feeling too
where it's like if I don't eat meat will
they stop killing animals will they stop
doing the factory farms no right so then
it's just like it sounds like an
thing to say though so it's like I don't
like saying it yeah but I also like if
everyone collectively says all right we
can all shake hands and agree we're not
gonna do this I'll be a part of it right
it's just me and it'll continue
regardless
yeah it is right it is and I totally get
people being like well I do it just for
me so I feel better about myself and
like what I'm supporting when I'm not
sporting I'm totally for that I think
that's awesome one day I would like to
switch to words like if I know my meat's
coming from an ethical Source I think
that's really cool like if they have
like a hunter he goes out and he kills a
deer and you buy meat from that Hunter
who killed a deer because there was too
many honored reservation or somewhere
like I would love to switch to where
it's like I'm only helping the
environment and nothing is going to
waste and all that I don't know if I
could ever get to that point or what
service you would even use for that but
I think that kind of thing could be like
a much better solution yeah it's just
like yeah just 30 day chickens like
that's so sad they just grow up to just
be like yeah
it was it the male chickens get killed
instantly it's so sad yeah yeah yeah but
that's also what we say but if let's say
we went to the grocery store and those
eggs were double the price or that meat
was double the price how many people are
actually going to choose that with their
wallet as well true but also at the same
point it's the same argument as
everything else it's like me choosing to
buy the more expensive ones not gonna
stop that because the other option is
still there yeah yeah and it's also a
tough situation because it's like if we
all collectively just stopped eating
meat that would put so many people who
have ranches and land out of business
and you might think like well good but
they're also the people that often grow
the crops and it's like well you're not
going to eat meat what are you going to
eat the plants but if they can't if they
can no longer afford to maintain the
land that the plants all also grow on
because the animals are probably some
more lucrative to sell cattle and stuff
then you also don't have a place to grow
plants so I think what really needs to
happen is that the government needs to
step in and have more regulations on
like Humane the production of like the
the meat where it's coming from the the
facility to make sure the animals are
taken care of not over production like I
just think there needs to be more
government regulation I don't think that
pressure should fall on the individual
consumer but it's hard to like I agree
to find any movement on that because you
can't just say let's not eat meat
because right now is currently like the
the whole farming industry that's the
more profitable market and you don't
have places to grow plants if that's the
alternative so it's like yeah have you
guys heard about the Monopoly on crops
no so there's an entire YouTube video I
watch and basically these companies that
make the seeds for crops they have like
a IP on the seed so they sell the seed
to a farmer the farmer plants it they
grow a crop but the farmer cannot
replant that seed or replant seeds from
that crop because that company had
genetically modified that seed to be
able to whatever grow faster better you
know more more yield they have to re-buy
the ability to be able to plant it
that's crazy yeah so
I didn't know you could have
intellectual property on genetics so
that was crazy yeah so wow I don't know
just another there ever they always try
to control something I've also read that
like um with the plans that are
genetically modified to grow faster is
that they're not as nutrient dense
because they didn't have time to mature
and get all the nutrients out of it so
they're actually not as healthy as like
the original plant
for you
so that's like another weird thing right
yeah to think about it's like do you
want it fast or do you want the health
benefits like the full nutrient value
that's kind of the point right yeah
that's the point of the organic non-GMO
whatever food yeah yeah
that's what people say like I don't see
a difference I don't taste a difference
like it's not in the taste
I said what it's like doing to your body
it's not like it's harming your body
you're just not getting as much
nutrients out of it yeah so I gotta say
you're very well spoken and yeah you're
an incredibly smart business yeah you
should be doing more podcasts see the
problem is it doesn't make money for me
I think if you go on podcasts with
different audiences yes I mean the
amount of exposure plus if they do Clips
they do shorts
absolutely but having my own business
yeah having your own I don't know but
after we had our first so after we had
Stella Berry on our podcast
um I'll say like probably since then
probably 50 only fans like models and
stuff have like reached out like some
pretty big ones too of like DM desk like
hey can I get on the iced coffee or can
I do this can I do that yeah no
definitely like I love doing podcasts
and other people's but like throwing my
own it's kind of hard because if you
already have a community of like guys
guys don't necessarily want to hear
women talk about serious subjects it has
to be more of like the what's that
really successful girl podcast so they
just talk about their things yes that
type of thing typically for like if you
have a Coomer audience right no caller
Dad I've listened to it it's really good
yeah some really good people on there
yeah yeah well recently as of late like
in the beginning the podcast oh yeah I
don't know about the beginning yeah I
really enjoyed it yeah I haven't
listened to it recently yeah but no I
definitely love doing podcasts for sure
I find them a refreshing Pace yeah cool
refreshing change of pace thank you so
much thank you for your hospitality guys
by the way she bought a sushi okay she
also like ubered us and showed us her
her horses okay so she's been which is
on the Vlog gracious yeah
she's been absolutely incredible very
very kind person so thank you really
appreciate it anytime you come to Vegas
let us know um
feel free to say whatever you want to
the cameras if you want to shout
something out yeah if you guys want to
follow me anywhere the most reliable
place is going to be my linktree
downbad.com is a URL because who knows
by the time you watch this maybe my
usernames will be completely different I
don't know but downbed.com easy to
remember cool thank you so much and
until next time